[airplane roars]
WOMAN ON INTERCOM: Welcome
to Hartfield-Jackson
Atlanta International Airport.
We're looking
through the LOB, left
over bags that passengers left
out there for whatever reason.
When passengers leave bags,
we gotta go through them, make
sure there's nothing illegal.
OFFICER AMADOR:
Depending on the day,
you can get about 30, 40 LOBs.
They are the people
that are in a hurry,
and they think they're
going to miss the flight,
and they'd rather
leave the bag behind.
Or the reason we
check, the person
might not want to get
caught bringing something
and leave the bag behind.
OFFICER MAINOR: When
I go through the bags,
I try and be methodical.
I try not to overlook anything.
[bags rustling]
Coffee beans.
I can't really see inside it.
I'mma have to cut it open.
Got a coffee smell, but
we'll see what we got.
[suspense music]
Coffee is supposed
to be brown, right?
OFFICER MAINOR: Coffee is
not supposed to be white.
[theme music]
Now we just cut open
the rest and see.
And again.
Oh, wow.
OK.
Try not to get too
high or too low
because you know
you got to test it.
But when you start
seeing the same thing,
you're like, oh, OK.
That's not the norm.
OFFICER SMILEY: No, he didn't.
MALE 2: Oh, yes he did.
[chuckles]
OFFICER SMILEY: So this
was inside the coffee?
OFFICER MAINOR: Mm-hm.
OFFICER SMILEY: Gotcha.
So do they look, like,
commercially packaged?
OFFICER MAINOR Yeah.
It looked legit because
see how it's stitched?
Sometimes you just
can't skip steps.
It's that simple.
It's that easy.
So now we're going to test
it and see what we have.
MALE 3: What do you think?
OFFICER MAINOR: Mm-hm.
[suspense music]
Hold on.
It's hot.
MALE 3: There you go.
It's reading
cocaine hydrochloride,
so that's cocaine.
It's just straight cocaine.
No mixture, no nothing else.
You know, it's a good day.
OFFICER SMILEY: Nice catch.
[music playing]
OFFICER MAINOR: 3.51 kilos.
Yeah.
That's a lot.
Since I've been
here, this is one
of the largest ones we've had.
That's over a year and a half.